nous avons acheté des sacs de crevettes
congelées à toronto calgary montréal et
saskatoon 14 contenait des bactéries
potentiellement dangereuses et 9 étaient
porteurs de bactéries pathogènes
résistantes à au moins un antibiotique 5
provenaient de l'inde 2 de chine et les
deux autres de thaïlande et du vietnam
est un enjeu mondial mais j'ai l'article
dit que peu été utilisé au canada mais
il est utilisé en asie avec les usa se
retrouve dans mon assiette qui est
arrivé en utilisant les antibiotiques
depuis 70 ans on exposait un grand
nombre de bactéries
un grand nombre de molécules et les
bactéries ont tout simplement sortis de
leur génome les manières de se défendre
ici une seule bactérie le stemi temps et
peut-être capable d'éclairer mais si
c'est une quantité grande ses plus
grandes si la personne est obligée de se
présenter à l'hôpital
et là si on doit utiliser un
antibiotique la bactérie résistante qui
est à la base à travers n'entrave avisés
de nos résultats
santé canada nous indique que la lutte à
l'antibiorésistance est une priorité et
que le gouvernement songeait à inclure
les fruits de mer dans le programme de
surveillance ce qu'il ne fait pas
actuellement
lorsque je regarde les bactéries e.coli
clip ciolos n'a pas réussi la salle
monnet la surface de crever elles sont
surtout à l'extérieur de la crevette
parce qu'elles ont été en contaminer à
sion avec l'environnement dont on parle
et la salubrité manquants il faut donc
traiter les crevettes comme le poulet
pour diminuer le risque de contamination
croisée est ce que vous les achetez crue
ou cuite un rsa japon est nécessaire
avant la cuisson qui elle détruira par
la chaleur les bactéries à la surface
ici denis gagné radio canada montréal